Trump versus the GOP again that's the
focus of tonight's angle when will they
learn more than a year into president
Trump's first term you think that all
the Republicans would understand that
the only way forward is to unify behind
his agenda it's resonating with the
people it's bringing international foes
to the negotiating table and it's having
a positive impact on the economy but
some Republicans cannot help but lend
aid and comfort to the president's
political enemies so it's Trump slowly
but surely begins to remake the GOP to
be more responsive to working-class
Americans the globalist wing of the
party is still in total denial and the
old guards resistance to Trump of course
big shocker is being amplified by a
media machine that's been trying to take
him down ever since he first came down
that golden escalator just watch how
uncomfortable some of these Republicans
are when pressed about whether they'd
support the president again in 2020 any
Republican senator that hasn't been
conflicted over this presidency is
either comatose or is pretty useless in
their blindness and prepared at this
point to towards the president for
re-election in 2020 I haven't even
thought about that like you know it's
way too early you supported the eye
who's president who's the head of your
party it could be a completely different
world by 2020 we have a 2018 election
first rather than just rallying behind
the president and a show of total unity
before the midterms some in the party
end up just giving the media what they
want a story line about a divided GOP
the Republican Party of Abraham
Lincoln's time is centered in the south
and Trump is a guy from New York always
somewhat alien territory the
Conservatives this reflects a division
not only within the Republican Party
with the approach to Russia but within
his own administration
the Republican Party of Paul Ryan or
Trump I mean that's that's the best
there's no choice it's the Republican
Party of Donald Trump watches why Paul
Ryan's leaving but the truth is if you
want to see real disunity look at the
Democrats they have no real leader
they've moved so far left they've left
America and they're reduced now to
either silly antics or stammering and
their attempts to rile up their base
it's a scam the tax bill that gets 83%
of the benefits to the top 1% ain't it
they try to call it a middle class tax
cut and yet 86 million middle class
families in the life of this bill will
be paying more taxes we'll bring in an
interpreter next time well the Democrats
come on they're so desperate they've now
sued the Trump campaign WikiLeaks and of
course the Russians over Hillary
Clinton's loss in 2016 Donald Trump has
been saying for a year plus this is all
about sour grapes it's all because you
lost an election what does that better
than the Democratic National Committee
suing them and saying he lost us this
election good luck David asked a lot of
thing it seems like a whole waste of
time and resources oh of course it is
the Democrats can't even agree on a
political strategy Tom Perez and the DNC
of filing lawsuits while other prominent
liberals are just shaking their heads
fretting over their re-election
prospects Senator Claire McCaskill told
the st. Louis post-dispatch that the DNC
lawsuit is just a silly distraction and
congresswoman Jackie Speier hardly a
moderate she said this I actually think
this lawsuit is ill-conceived and I am
not very supportive of it that is what
real disunity looks like so beyond all
the bluster and all the media attacks on
the president Trump's re-election
numbers check them out they actually
look pretty good they mirror those of
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton at about
the same point in their presidencies
today's Gallup reports that among
registered voters 37 percent believed
Trump should be reelected
that's the same percentage that thought
Barack Obama should be re-elected in
2010 and at one point lower than those
that supported Bill Clinton in 94 big
deal well last time I checked both Obama
and Clinton were re-elected for a second
term right
here's another leading indicator that
the Democratic National Committee might
be in some trouble
well they took out a one point seven
million dollar loan in February huh
so they're fundraising a good measure of
voter excitement it's pathetic meanwhile
the Republican National Committee took
in a whopping 39 million dollars in the
first quarter alone I think that might
be because of the president well of
course the president has some work to do
he still has to grow the populist
movement take his message to unfriendly
territory and sell it that means even in
states where he didn't win grow his base
but while the Democrats are in perpetual
tear down and resistance mode I'm
telling you Trump should be perceived as
a doer he is a leader who will always
defy and drain the swamp will not be
defeated by it that's why he was elected
in the first place all the president
needs to do is just stay focused on what
matters
growing the economy returning more power
to the people fighting corruption along
the way and refusing to be distracted or
deterred by the constant and tedious
demonization game of Washington and the
seemingly endless pointless
investigations I know that's easier said
than done but he needs to do that now
listen to all the naysayers you want but
Trump's re-election prospects and those
of his party on our on more solid ground
than the media or his critics would have
you believe and that's the angle